[MUSIC]
Ten years ago,
I worked with my friend Luke on
the hot dusty plains of West Texas.
I recently reconnected with Luke, and
when I did he shared with
me an unsettling story.
When Luke was in college and
recently married,
he came across an abandoned hunting riffle
which he dutifully took down to
the local police station to turn in.
While he was there, he was told that
the riffle had been reported missing and
he was under arrest for possession of
a stolen firearm, a serious felony.
Luke spent the next six days In jail on
charges that were ultimately dropped.
For the first three days his wife had no
idea where he was because she had an out
of state cell phone number and the jail
wouldn't allow long distance calls.
What was it that kept Luke in jail not
just over night but, for six days?
It was bail set at $100,000.
Now if your college jobs were
all like mine which at one point included
campus bookstore return specialist.
>> [LAUGH]
>> $100,000 was just
way beyond out of reach and
it was for Luke too.
But bail is rigid.
It isn't means tested.
It's an old system that needs reform
to better align with our values.
We live in a society that values the
promise of liberty and justice for all.
But our pre-trial justice system is only
delivering liberty and justice for some.
So today, can we do three things together?
First, let's take a walk into
this pretrial justice system.
Something that you may have never thought
about and until recently I hadn't either.
Second, let's consider if it matters
whether someone spends the time
between their arrest and
their trial in jail.
And third, let's look at ways that you and
I will interact with
the system going forward.
Before we get going, I just feel
an obligation to acknowledge that I am not
the typical person to
address a topic like this.
I've had a lucky upbringing.
Nobody in my family spent time in jail,
but
it makes me angry to think about Luke and
his wife separated for six days.
And it isn't just Luke, every night in
the US, 700,000 people sit in local jails.
60% of them are there just waiting for
their trial.
So to walk into this system.
After a rest,
everyone will face one three doors.
So, door number one, release.
This is for people who are low risk, not
too much of a danger to the community and
are likely to show up to
all of their court dates.
They're free to go until
the time of their trial.
Door number two, detention.
This is where people who are high risk.
They may not be likely to show up
to all of their court dates or
they may have been charged with
a particularly egregious offense and so
they'll stay in jail until
the time of the trial.
Door number three.
Bail.
This is the door that most
people have to walk through.
Bail requires that someone
deposited money with the court
that they will only get back even when
they show up for all of their court dates.
And if you think about it, that's
kind of a good system and principle.
I mean, we want some sort of incentive for
people to show up for court.
But when you dig into the data,
it's clear this is a tricky
door to have to walk through.
You see in San Jose two years ago,
the average bail amount was $27,000.
$27,000 is enough to buy a brand new
Toyota Camry with leather seats or
make a down payment on a house
anywhere outside of the bay area.
[LAUGH] This is like a lot of money.
And to me this is compelling evidence
that our pre-trial justice system
keeps people in jail simply based
on who can and who cannot pay.
So on the one hand you have people with
means, who can pay their way out of jail
regardless of their risk of society, and
on the other hand you have people like
Luke, people who are stuck behind
bars simply because they can't pay.
Now, to topic number two,
it doesn't matter if someone spends
this time between arrest and
trial, in jail or not.
If someone is unable to pay bill, they can
wait for weeks or months for that trial.
And over the course of that time,
they're at risk of losing a job.
A relationship with a significant
other and if and when they do get out,
it is that much harder to put
food on the table or pay rent.
Now, it isn't just this
sort of run of the mill,
everyday life stuff that gets,
that changes.
Brooklyn defender services looked at
two groups of people that they serve in
New York City.
Group number one,
these are folks who stayed in jail between
the time of their arrest and trial.
And group number two,
these are people who got out.
You know what they found.
Group number one was five times
more likely to end up with
a criminal conviction.
Five times.
And you know what contributes to this.
It's the fact that when you're in jail
it's hard to meet with your lawyer.
It's hard to build your case.
And some people will plead guilty
simply to move the process along.
But that criminal conviction follows them
when they apply for jobs in the future or
try to rent an apartment.
And so the bottom line here is
that getting out really matters.
To illustrate this, I'd like to share
the story of Kalief Browder, and
some of you maybe
familiar his tragic tale.
Kalief was a 16 year old living in
New York City when he was arrested for
allegedly stealing a backpack.
His bail was set at only $3000.
But he and
his family couldn't afford that.
Calif spent the next three
years on Rikers Island,
a notorious jail facility
in New York in New York.
At the end of those three years.
His charges were dropped.
And he wasn't convicted of anything.
And sadly just a couple years after
his release, Kalief committed suicide.
And many point to the mental and
emotional trauma of his time in jail
as a major contributing factor.
So how does this happen.
I mean this is insane.
$3,000 cost him 3 years and his life.
Kalief didn't have his liberty and
as a result he lost his shot at justice.
So again, the bottom line here is
the getting out really matters.
How are you and I going to interact
with this system going forward?
Now, we may never have to walk
through anyone of these three doors.
But you're going to read articles
about this topic online and
you'll be asked to vote on criminal
justice reform issues in your home state.
I am not the only person talking about
this, John Oliver did a spot on bail.
The New York Times and
NPR are writing about it.
And Jay-Z actually just produced a mini
series on the Kalief Browder story.
So read these articles and get informed
because you will be asked to weigh in.
I'd like to share two examples of this.
In 2014, New Jersey passed
a ballot measure that did away
with their old money bail system.
And he replaced it with a risk algorithm.
What this does is, it scores every
defendant on a scale from one to six.
It's based on their likelihood
of not showing up to court and
the risk to the community.
This score based on their actual
risk is what determines whether they
stay in jail or not.
It's not their ability to pay.
And while these algorithms
are not perfect by any means
they're an important step
forward in the right direction.
A little bit closer to home, there's
actually a bill working its way through
the California legislature currently
that would have similar effects.
So this is relevant for us right now.
It would shift people
from door number three,
bail through door number 1, release.
Now, for the last year, I've been working
with a team of students here in Stanford
for a business based
solution to this problem.
And if this is at all interesting to you,
I'm all ears please come talk to me.
Small interested folks like yourselves,
are critical for
coming up with a better system.
So I want you to leave here
today knowing that this matters.
This matters to the Lukes.
It matters to the Kaliefs.
And it matters to thousands of others
who are trapped in our pre-trial
justice system.
So let's renew a commitment to our values.
And let's take an important step forward
in delivering on the promise of liberty
and justice, not just for some,
but liberty and justice for all.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]